Speaker 1: There is. A major
threat from Kuhnen, though,
it isn't just insurrection, it isn't just
playful ideas about wacky conspiracy theories.
There are other elements that have
that have human effect an impact.
This headline is a tragedy. From The New York
Times, look, I'm I'm a I'm a father. And to.
To think about the state of mind
of this man who killed his kids.
With a speargun. Because of Kuhnen.
It's remarkable. I don't understand
how someone can go through with this
and be convinced of things that are so out of
this world. Reading from The New York Times,
surf instructor killed his children and claimed
Kuhnen made him do it. FBI says a California
surfing instructor confessed to killing his two
children with a spear fishing gun after abducting
them, telling investigators that his belief in
the conspiracy theories known as Kuhnen made
him do it, the authorities said on Wednesday. The
father, Matthew Taylor Coleman of Santa Barbara.
Drove his two two year old son and 10 month
old daughter to Mexico over the weekend
and fatally shot them on Monday, according to
an FBI investigator and a nine page criminal
affidavit that was filed in U.S. district
court in Los Angeles on Wednesday. The FBI
special agent wrote that Mr. Coleman told the
authorities that he knew what he did was wrong.
But that it was the only course of action that
would save the world. Norm Coleman stated that
he believed his children were going to grow into
monsters, so he had to kill them. Special Agent
Jennifer Bannon wrote she wrote this, Norm Coleman
explained that he was enlightened by Kuhnen and
Illuminati conspiracy theories and was receiving
visions and signs revealing that his wife,
Acee, possessed serpent DNA and had passed
it on to his children. Mr. Coleman described
himself as adherent of Kuhnen, the pro Trump
conspiracy movement whose followers hold closely,
hold falsely excuse me that a cabal of Democrats
and coastal elites engage in pedophilia
and worship Satan. The conspiracy movement
has been the subject of warnings by the FBI
that his followers would resort
to violence. And they are right.
The FBI was right. The warnings were right.
The Homeland Security Department is right.
This guy took his kids to Mexico and
shot him in the chest with a spear gun.
Imagine the agony, the death. The suffering,
that's not a quick that's not a quick ending
to a life. Their father did this. Kuhnen is
not just a playful. Set of goofy thoughts.
It's not. It is nothing but virulent and sickening
and dangerous, and now two children won't grow.
To be adults. And this guy is going to
go to prison for the rest of his life.
A mother doesn't have her kids
anymore. Because if Kuhnen.